They're not haters, but they just don't know Allah the way you want to know Allah.
So they'll be like, "Oh, did you try hard enough?"
You You ever put in a dozen applications and then have that one auntie or uncle
be like, "But did you try?"
You like, "Yo, we about to fight, yo."
Like, "What you mean, did I try?"
But then you need people in your life that will remind you of this name of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
And so what did he I'm going to repeat this now.
He says, "A Razak is the one that has chosen the wealthy people and given them
provision. But those who don't have in a moment, he has provided them with something greater,
which is the witnessing of the provider.
And this is a question for me, for you, for all of us.
Ask yourself this question in your heart.
Would you rather the provision or a relationship with the provider?
Because a lot of us listening right now, they're like, "Shake, sounds good, but I want
the money." Okay, let's keep it honey.
Let's keep it real.
That's what's going through your heart right now.
But what if that money doesn't provide you what you what you thought it was going
to give you? How many people in this room are are are are extremely wealthy people
and they sitting there nodding because they got the wealth but no contentment?
They got the house but no tranquility in the house.
They they have what you thought if I got it I'd be good.
And so so if we may digress for a moment, what we were realizing is the
money is not the objective.
Allah is the objective.
And then when I realize that I realize that he may give me money but it
not have the objective I thought the money was going to get me.
All right.
Alhamdulillah.
Oh Allah, we ask you to uh make our hearts filled with light, the light of
knowing who you are.
And our last uh session, this whole series is about getting to know who Allah subhana
wa ta'ala is. And and what is what is Ramadan except an intimate connection with Allah
subhana wa ta'ala on a level that we don't get any other time of the year.
And the closest way to know someone is to know their attributes, know who they are.
And so the same thing Allah subhana wa ta'ala tells us
that Allah subhanaa tala has these beautiful names that you have to learn.
You have to study.
But that's not all.
You have to use these names.
You have to call Allah subhana wa tala by these names.
And um tonight inshallah uh we'll talk about a name of Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
Um, we've been doing like 18 19 sessions and I actually don't know if we did
this name already, low-key.
But, but, but I'll tell you something.
Um, because it's Ramadan,
I said to myself, it doesn't matter if we did this name again because of the
time and the season that we're in right now.
Whether it be because of Ramadan, whether it be because of the economic situation that we
exist within,
um, job scarcity, difficulty with with provisions.
Tonight, I want to study the beautiful name of Allah subhana wa tala.
Alak
is the name that I want us to study tonight.
And Allah subhana wa ta'ala he tells us so much about himself in the Quran.
But one of the attributes that is ex essential for us to understand on a deep
level is that there is no one that controls our provision.
what we call in Arabic risk risk there is no one that controls your provision except
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala because he is al-Q is the only one that provides for you
and there are so many verses where Allah subhana wa ta'ala talks about this in the
Quran and and this may be one of the names of Allah subhana wa t'ala that
is mentioned the most in the Quran like legit mentioned the most and and the reason
is if you don't know this name the level of anxiety that you go through in
life is unparalleled.
The level of worries that you have about tomorrow,
about what will happen next week, about how will I take care of this, how will
I take care of that.
If you were to sit here and think about all of the financial things you have
to be there for, all of the emotional things that you have to provide for, all
the people you have to be there for, if you were to think about that right
now, it causes a lot of stress.
Like I'm thinking about these little three kids at home and and and they're chilling, but
I'm like, "Yo, college is like right down the street, bro."
I talked to my wife.
I was like, "Yo, we doing state schools, yo."
You know what I mean?
We going local. Because the idea is this this responsibility or burden of providing
Allah subhana wa ta'ala, he tells us about himself so that we remove that burden from
us. that we take that burden off of ourselves and realize that though my children look
up to me as Baba the one who provides what they don't realize is Baba is
not the one that provides Baba is just the means by which Allah subhana wa ta'ala
provides for them
and the moment we start to realize this name there is a n or a light
that comes to our heart that removes all types of anxieties all types of worries and
people will come to you like how are you trusting so much how are you so
calm and they'll realize realize that you don't have everything figured out, but all you have
figured out is that you have nothing to figure out.
All you have to do is trust in Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
So this name of Allah subhana wa ta'ala is profound.
Allah subhana wa ta tells us and I'm going to start with the Quran.
He says
in the heavens is your risk is your provisions
and everything that you have been promised.
What the scholars they say they say it's out of reach for you until Allah brings
it down for you.
When you reach for what's not yours yet, you find yourself in sin, you find yourself
in anxiety, you find yourself in all of these worries.
So he begins by saying,
Why? Why would you tell me that, ya Allah?
So that I realize that all this effort I'm doing down here on the earth is
not to get it.
It's already written. It's already written.
And then Allah says,
he says, "I swear."
Allah is saying, "I swear by myself, the Lord of the heavens and earth.
I swear to you that this is true.
Just as much as you know you're speaking right now when you read these verse, know
that it is true that I am the one in control of your risk and your
sustenance."
What is the cost of not knowing this name?
The cost of not knowing this name number one
and these aren't in order of hierarchy but just understanding what is at risk if in
this Ramadan you don't what is at risk if you don't understand who controls your risk
what is at what is at what is at stake here number one cost if you
don't know this name you become a slave to the means instead of the master of
the means number one you become a slave to the means
There's a hadith where the prophetat wasam he said wretch be the one who is the
slave of the dollar and the the din the gold and the silver because the idea
is not to have the idea is not to not have it.
The idea is that you are steadily connected to the one who is the one that
gives it. And this is what we talked about in Jum this week and it really
connects to Ramadan because Ramadan is the time of generosity.
time of generosity
and this is based on the hadith where
he says
that
that was the most generous of people most generous of people just off the strength of
who he was naturally the most generous of people
but then he says
Ramadan but the time that he was most generous was in the month of Ramadan on.
But why? The question is is why?
When you understand the equation between risk and your giving, you understand what this hadith teaches.
In Ramadan, the prophet sallallaihi wasallam was reading Quran with Gabriel every night.
He was seeing the constant flow of so much baraka and blessing.
And the idea here is this.
you will see an increase in your risk, your provisions.
And I want to talk about what risk actually is.
Because for many of us when we say the word risk or provision, we think money.
We think that it means I'm going to make more money.
I'm going to get a promotion.
But we don't understand that even that money that you get is only a means to
what your true risk is.
Because what are you searching for in that dollar?
What are you searching for in that promotion?
Security,
tranquility.
But how many times does that money come and bring no security and no tranquility?
So even that is just the means.
So the first thing that comes is when a person knows who
is the name of Allah, they stop becoming a slave to the means and they become
a slave to the master of the means.
Why is this clutch?
Because there are people in our lives that would like to tell us they have control
of the means in our lives.
A boss, a colleague,
a a manager,
a parent,
all types of people in our lives will make us feel for moments that they control
whether we receive something or we don't receive something.
But you will live like a king and you will live like a queen.
The moment you realize you have no control over what Allah has already written for me,
you have no way to take away from me what God has written for me.
and you have no way to give me what Allah subhana wa ta'ala has not given
me. Imagine what that does to a person's psychology.
Imagine what that does to a person's state of living.
So the first thing that happens is if you don't know
you become a slave to the means instead of the master of the means.
Number two,
you'll never feel that you have enough
and scarcity mindset will kick in.
How did how did the saiam give so much?
How did he just give?
It's because he understood
that the where the place it was coming from never runs out.
The place that it's actually coming from, there's no shortage of it.
And so because he realized that he became a river of God's blessings to other people,
not a damn to God's blessings.
And this is the secret to increasing your risk.
I spoke about this in Juma, but I I want to double down on this.
Abdul Rahman bin was one of the most wealthy companions there were.
But on multiple occasions, Abdul Rahman bin emptied his entire portfolio for the sake of Allah.
How? It doesn't make sense when you do the math.
In today's time, he gave equivalent in charity to a quarter of a billion dollars in
charity.
In charity, that's how much he gave.
Now, your mind would think, subhan Allah, he must have died with very little.
No. When they counted up how much he left each of his wives, it equaled up
to a billion dollars.
It equal Who is this?
Abdahman Bino. because he understood an equation that Allah subhana wa ta'ala gives those who does
his work and continues to bless those people because they have become the means of blessing
other people
the moment you get married risk comes the moment you have a child ris comes the
moment you have another child r comes
there's a there's a hadith
I don't even know if I should share it because we too woke these days but
a man came to him and he was like yahool Allah it's it's hard times
this it's difficult man AI taking jobs you know what I mean it's getting difficult
soam said get married
counterintuitive
what you mean I'm I'm supposed to get married when I get the money
said just trust the process get married now I don't recommend y'all do this cuz y'all
ain't ready yet
like you have to be ready you have to be at that level where you truly
understand that Allah will provide.
So he got married and he came back few weeks months later he said yoolah I
did what you said but still tough times
he said I want you to try to get married again
I told you I told you y'all wasn't ready now we need a breakout session like
oh relax okay relax so he told him to get married again
he's like this doesn't make sense y Allah why again?
I'm barely providing for one wife and you want me to provide for two.
He said no get married again.
He said okay I'm going to trust my prophet.
My prophet knows he understands this dunya and he understands Allah on a different level and
he's teaching me something.
He got married a second time.
According to one narration he came back a second time.
The prophet told him to get married again.
And the third time he came sister said again.
The third time he came back, the third time he came back, he said, "Yeah, Allah
has provided for all of us."
Now,
and the prophet taught us something is that when you become a conduit of through which
people are provided
and you stop worrying,
stop worrying about it coming and you just give, that is when Allah blesses you to
just give, give, give.
That is how Abdul Rahman bin Oath gave a quarter of a billion dollars in charity
and died with a billion still in a portfolio.
That's how it happens because they understand who Razak is.
And so the scarcity mindset is something no believer should live with.
And I say this in Ramadan because Ramadan is when we keep asking for donations, donations,
donations. And by the like the 16th of Ramadan, you're like, "Yo, I'm tapped out."
How many times can I become a sustainer?
Yo,
no, legit. Like, you're like, yo, but tonight what we realize is you stretch beyond your
mean in giving because he will go beyond what you believe he can do in giving
you.
That's the key right there.
And that's what I've learned through this name of Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
Whenever somebody asks for anything, just give.
Just give
and trust Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
I know it's counterintuitive.
I understand.
But this is the huck that wasallam has taught us and this is the equation.
I I was uh I was talking to a colleague of mine
and he was like, "Yo, what name are you doing tonight?"
I was like, "Razak."
He's like, "Can I tell you a story?"
I was like, "Please."
He was like um
I was working with a brother coaching him helping him in his field
and he he had his field he was growing
but
the money wasn't coming the way he expected it to.
So he said we had a long conversation about this name of Allah and we worked
on this name of Allah and we worked specifically on one aspect
don't trust the means just seek the master of the means
stop worrying about the amount in the checking or savings account and focus on God only.
He said within 3 to four weeks the brother came back and he says I cannot
explain to you how much Allah has just opened up to me.
I I can't put it into words how much Allah has just opened the doors up.
But all he did was switch his focus from the means to the master of the
means. And he did that.
And when that happens, the scarcity mindset goes away because you realize there's no limitation on
what God could give me.
There's no limitation on what Allah subhana wa ta'ala can give me.
And so this name removes from us the greed, the envy for what others have.
Subhan Allah. A lot of us we struggle with jealousy.
Jealousy of a cousin, a sister, a friend, a colleague.
But when you understand that the one providing them is the same one providing you, all
of a sudden why would I be jealous over you?
You got the same master as me.
The same one that provided you is providing me.
Why would I be jealous?
Scarcity mindset is what fuels jealousy.
And I mentioned this before.
Ll made a quintessential mistake.
He forgot that there was room at the top for all of us.
Shaitan, he made a quintessential mistake.
He thought that spot that Adam had was reserved for one.
He didn't realize there was room for more.
There was room for more.
scarcity mindset destroys your relationship with God
because it shows him you don't trust.
So, how do how do we overcome this?
Give till it hurts.
Yo,
give till it hurts.
We can all give when it don't hurt.
But right when you start to think a little, that's when you're doing God's work.
At that point, right when it starts to hurt, keep giving.
What's the next thing that happens?
If you don't know this name Razak and truly know it, truly know it means what
y'all? I don't care who my boss is.
I don't care if I get a pink slip, they still give those.
It's just an email, right?
They call you to HR.
You could cry all you want to HR.
They trained to not be affected by tears.
Yo, don't matter. HR comes comes in, you're good.
You're you're you're you're at peace.
And and I want to add something here.
What is better? I this I'm going to read this quote that I read from one
of the scholars that just blew my mind.
He said
sometimes
God will not open the doors of risk for you.
But you can't look at any one name in isolation.
When you see the doors of risk are closed, you have to understand there's something else
he's giving me there.
There's the name of Allah Alhim, which we didn't study yet.
The name of Allah the all wise, the name of Allah Alim, the one who's aware
and alas, the one who sees me right now.
So one scholar he says
al- Razak is the one
who has
chosen the wealthy
to have risk
but selected
those improvished
with witnessing who is the razor
he gave the wealthy risk but what did he give the poor they witness who Razak
is how many wealthy people don't ever witness who the true Razak is their whole life.
And so I bring this up.
Why? Because if you are in a moment right now,
there was a a brother uh in our community, mashallah, man.
And like all of us, man, job security is you think you're secure, but you don't
know tomorrow what's going to happen.
You don't you don't know what's going to happen.
And I remember this clear as day last year.
one of the brothers in the haka.
He's like, "Yo, I just got fired, man.
Just got fired, bro."
And and and we just sat and I was like, "Yo, we just we just we
needed each other in that moment."
And 6 months later, application after application, we know the drill.
No response. No response.
No response. After a while of no responses, Shayan starts to tell you like, "Yo,
what is Allah going to provide?"
And I kid you not, this this man, he said,
"In that time, I got closer to Allah than I had ever been with the job.
I got closer to Allah than I had ever been with the job.
And after about 8 months, he got a job.
He was good." But he said that dark phase wasn't dark.
It was light because I got to know God in that phase.
Now, here's the problem.
you have a lot of they're not haters, but they just don't know Allah the way
you want to know Allah.
So they'll be like, "Oh, did you try hard enough?"
You You ever put in a dozen applications and then have that one auntie or uncle
be like, "But did you try?"
You like, "Yo, we about to fight."
Yo,
like what you mean, did I try?
But then you need people in your life that will remind you of this name of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
And so what did he I'm going to repeat this now.
He says al raak is the one that has chosen the wealthy people and given them
provision.
But those who don't have in a moment he has provided them with something greater which
is the witnessing of the provider.
And I ask you and this is a question for me for you for all of
us. Ask yourself this question in your heart.
Would you rather the provision or a relationship with the provider?
Because a lot of us listening right now, they're like, "Shake, sounds good, but I want
the money." Okay, let's keep it 100.
Let's keep it real.
That's what's going through your heart right now.
But what if that money doesn't provide you what you what you thought it was going
to give you?
How many people in this room are are are extremely wealthy people and they sitting there
nodding because they got the wealth but no contentment?
They got the house but no tranquility in the house.
They they have what you thought if I got it I'd be good.
And so so if if we may digress for a moment.
What we were realizing is Allah is not the the the money is not the objective.
Allah is the objective.
And then when I realized that I realized that he may give me money but it
not have the objective I thought the money was going to get me.
And I'm only speaking about money right now, but I'm going to go deeper into this
concept of risk because we have limited risk to only be money.
But now you should realize that if you're given contentment
with little money, would you rather have that?
And there's a hadith so profound that said the little bit that causes contentment is better
than the a lot that drives you crazy.
That drives you crazy.
That hadith is so profound because it actually puts things in its place.
Don't ask Allah for
that number of wealth.
Ask Allah for that contentment
cuz that's what you're truly searching for.
And tonight, I want you to really think about that example.
How many walk the red carpet?
Lives are miserable.
Lives are mis miserable.
But in the back of your head, you're like, "Yeah, shake, but I'd be different if
I had it."
You'd only be different if you understood this name of Allah.
And that's how Abdman bin was different.
Abdman bin O has the billion dollars at the time of his death,
but he's built different
and Allah could give it to him because it won't trip him up.
But for me and you, there was a verse I was reading today.
Crazy
verse.
Allah subhana wa ta'ala says
because right now you may be thinking but why hasn't my doors open yet?
How come you haven't given me yet?
Listen to this verse in
verse number 37
or 27. I can't even see 27
risk right there.
If Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala was to just open up your provisions, meaning everything you want,
everything you want, if he was just to just open up,
look what Allah says about the human nature,
you would run a muck.
You know, run a muck, you'd be wilding out.
You'll be tripping.
If Allah just opened it up,
you would be just reckless,
reckless.
But then Allah says,
"However,
he sends it down in portion so that you get it and you're ready for it
when you get it."
That's a
So, so how do I prove to Allah that I'm ready for my portfolio to 10x?
I got to donate 10x.
I got y'all ain't ready.
Yo, I am so hyped with this name right now
because I feel like I understand the secret to that risk.
You just got to give, man.
You just got to give.
And then Allah subhana t he finishes the verse
but he sends it down in proportion
that he knows there's wisdom and then the verse isn't over
indeed he is of you.
He knows you
of you. He watches you.
He knows you. It's like a mother.
She knows when the baby is ready for food,
right? You You know when the baby the baby reaching out for the steak, you like,
"You ain't ready for that.
You're not ready for that steak yet.
You're not ready for this.
It's not time yet."
So my question is, am I ready to be blessed by God?
That's the question I have for myself.
And if I want to, if I want that, I have to open up.
I have to open up like Abdman O.
People will think you're crazy.
I'm telling you they will.
But don't tell them.
You know why? Hadith says when you give charity, do it so quiet.
Right hand doesn't know what the left hand is given.
To me, that's wifey.
I'll be giving charity.
Don't even tell her.
I was at a fundraiser the other day, raised my hand.
She was like, "What?"
I was like, "Oh, I forgot."
Give charity quietly.
Give charity quietly
understanding
that the one that gave it to you will give you manyfold more.
He is Razak.
Again, I'll use the metaphor.
Don't be a damn to God's blessings.
Be a river to God's blessings.
That's it.
And once you become a river, no one, everyone like, "Yo, what's your secret?
What's your secret?"
And you'll be like, "You'll never believe what the secret is."
Let's go forward.
The next h thing that happens if you don't know this name of Allah,
you don't know this name of Allah,
you will humiliate yourself in front of people.
You will disgrace yourself, humble yourself, and humiliate yourself before the creation because you think they
got some control over what you want.
You'll do whatever they ask.
The job is asking you to miss Juma's.
Okay, I guess I got to miss Juma.
Go online, get a fatwa.
All of those things that they're going to ask you to cross those red lines,
you'll cross each one to the point you don't even recognize yourself.
You're at the top, but you don't even know who you are anymore.
You're at the top.
You're at the top, but you don't even know who you are because you've crossed your
line so many times.
If you don't know Razak, you won't have a red line to put.
You'll just humble yourself to everyone, every client, every potential lead, every potential sale, every one
of those. You just keep humbling, humbling before you don't even know who you are.
You should have been humbling yourself to Allah Razak, but you humbled yourself to the people
because you think they controlled your risk.
Imagine how everything changes when you realize you're not in control.
You're not in control.
Back in the day there was a like like three four years ago we used to
say like miss me with that
like miss me with that to me miss me with that is like
you control my risk miss me with that bro like that's not hitting me
for a moment you may fall susceptible but that's why you have people around you that's
why this haka right here bookmark it man
bookmark this one
this is the one that reminds you no one is in control of my risk except
Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
What do people do?
You flatter them. You stay silent when you should speak up.
How many of us were in corporate when Gaza was happening?
We couldn't speak up.
I have a colleague.
He works for Google.
Good job. Like that.
Good Google money, bro.
He quit.
They're like, "You can't post that stuff."
He's like, "I could do what I want.
You're not in control."
Quit. Boom.
Some of y'all like word like
I'm not telling you to to be reckless.
I'm telling you the power of knowing this name.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm simply telling you the power of knowing this name.
And mashallah he's doing good.
Mashallah.
And he's doing better cuz his heart is at peace.
Alhamdulillah.
I sacrificed a little bit for the people of Gaza.
Again, I'm not saying be reckless.
I just want you to leave tonight having a whole different outlook on who controls what.
And that's the benefit of this name.
If we look throughout the Quran,
we are provided with plenty of examples of people who understood.
And what I find most beautiful is that many of the examples were the women in
the Quran.
A woman with her dean and connection with God
undefeated bro.
Undefeated.
You cannot beat a a Muslim who knows God.
You cannot beat her.
The first example is Mariam.
Mariam
Mariam has so much.
She has so much trust in God.
She eating strawberries and grapes in the middle of winter, bro.
Zakaria walks in.
He's a prophet of God.
But he goes, "Where do you get this from?"
She goes,
she goes, "Allah provides whoever he wants without any reckoning."
meaning
I know this doesn't make sense for me to have it right now
but what doesn't make sense is if you don't know who Razak is and you limit
his ability to give you
and you so Mariam is the first one and she has such strong understanding of Razak
that her energy flows off to him he goes in the room and makes dua for
a kid he's 95 years old
he goes he go he her energy is so strong
that he goes in the other room and it's like, "You
giving fruit out of season?
I'm well past my season."
And wifey, she well past her season, too.
But he said, "Let me ask.
Let me ask."
The next example I give,
an amazing woman from the Quran, not necessarily directly in the Quran, but Hajisam
when Abraham dropped her off at Mecca
till today, we symbolically go between Saf and Marwa back and forth and we run in
between where the green lines are.
Why? Because that's how she ran.
Here's
what's crazy. She was running from one mountain to the next mountain looking for people because
people signify risk.
But in that moment, Allah provided from where she didn't expect right in the middle.
Zum opens up. She's looking up here.
Zum open up down here.
That trust in God.
And and the trust, if you're wondering, as Abraham was walking away,
she's yelling at him like, "How you
She's literally she's not sitting there like, "Oh, I see y'all."
No, she's she's hot.
But then she she realizes something.
She goes, "Well, hold on.
Has Allah ordered you to do this?"
And he says, "Yes."
And she goes, "Oh."
She goes, "Oh, no.
That we're good then."
Now, when he left, her normal motherly anxiety kicked in.
So she ran si which tells me you still got to work for this.
See she ran. She didn't just sit and like yo Allah zum zum
there was she did not chill.
She worked. She moved.
And this is what I need us to understand.
Your moving doesn't cause zum zum to flow.
Your moving just shows God I'mma do whatever I can but I know you're the provider.
Because you shouldn't leave the halaka today like I quit my job.
No, that's that's not Islam.
That is not Islam.
But the difference is the difference is
there are some of us
that believe
that their effort is what provides them.
And tonight we separate that.
This is formalities, man.
I'm doing formalities. I'mma try hard, but I'm doing formalities.
The clients that I land, the jobs that we land, that's Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
I'm going to do everything I can, but my heart rests assure.
And that's the believer.
The believer's hands are busy,
but their hearts are tranquil.
The believer's hands are busy.
They're trying. They're doing stuff, but their hearts are tranquil.
because they realize it's not my effort that makes it happen.
It's a Razak that makes it happen.
The next example of Razak,
I think the young men would appreciate this.
Musam.
Now your your situation may not line up with MS,
but there's a lot of brothers who listen to this Hakah series in prison and maybe
this will resonate with them.
MS fled Egypt a criminal.
He fled Egypt a criminal.
And he has no family.
He has no wealth.
He has nothing except his desire to do good for the sake of God.
That's it.
Within a short time, he arrives in Median.
Now, what did I tell you?
The secret to God blessing you is you bless others.
He arrives at a watering well.
You know the story.
There's these two sisters there with their flock
trying to water their their sheep,
but the men have crowded the space.
So he's like, "Yo, why don't y'all water your flock?"
They're like, "We can't.
All these men have to what are we going to do?"
So he goes, "Okay, no problem."
He goes over and he takes it upon himself.
Be a river, not a dam.
He takes it upon himself.
He had nothing to give except help.
He he he he feeds he waters the flock
and he goes back and he sits under the tree and he says to Allah,
he says, "Ya Allah, I'm in need.
I'm in need. I'm a fugitive.
I can't go back home.
I have nowhere forward to go to.
Where do I go?
Few hours later, guess who comes back?
The two sisters.
What y'all want?
My dad is calling you.
All
right.
Goes over to dad.
Dad cuts to the chase.
Dad cut. This was the best dad, man.
No small talk. No small talk.
What did he say?
He's like, I I want you to marry one of my daughters.
What does he say?
I ain't got no money.
He left a fugitive with no family.
Within a short time, not only does he have a job, he has a wifey, he
has a kid, he's on his way back to Mr.
meet his meet his mom.
Razak.
You're asking yourself, "What do I have?"
I remind you, you need nothing for God to provide for you.
Just give whatever you got.
Just become a conduit of giving.
That's the story of Moses right there.
Razak.
I said I want to talk about another thing because up till now
I would have us thinking that risk is only money.
But we should have understood something by now.
The scholars they say there's two types of types of risk.
Two types.
Two types of risk.
One is the material risk which is what we've been talking about so far.
The material means but there's another type of risk.
And this is really why I wanted to talk about this name in Ramadan.
The other is the spiritual risk.
And what do I mean by that?
I mean
knowledge of who Allah is,
recognition of God,
contentment of your heart,
uh confidence and trust in God.
All of these things are provisions that you have to turn to God for.
So in this month of Ramadan, we know this is a month of asking.
This is a month of begging.
My concern with myself is that I don't only ask God for material risk.
Because if that's all I ask Allah for, I've misunderstood the most important type of risk
that I need.
Oh Allah, I need you to remove my anxiety.
Oh Allah, I need confidence and trust in you.
Oh Allah, I need courage.
Oh Allah, I need Oh Allah, I need all of those things that are not material.
This is the month that we lock in and beg Allah subhana wa ta'ala to provide
us for those things.
Josie,
he lists
like seven
types of risks spiritually that God can give you.
Seven.
He says
the first type of risk that God can give your heart.
We already talked about money.
If you just came in, we already talked about money.
Now we going to the next level because we already came to the conclusion that God
could give me the money and not give me what I wanted through the money.
So now we have to ask Allah, oh Allah, provide for me the spiritual things that
my heart truly needs, that my mind truly needs.
Josie, he says there are seven levels of spirituality that God can open up and provide
you with. You got to ask for them though.
You got to want them.
Number one, the first thing he can do for you is he can empty your heart
of the dunya. Meaning you stop worrying so much about the dunya.
He takes it out of your heart.
This is an amazing blessing from Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
The first level,
level number two, and they don't have to come in any specific order.
Actually
number two
give you the sweetness of
the sweetness of ibada.
Hold on.
The sweetness
of ibada.
You ever see somebody
who just looks like they're enjoying?
Yo,
nah. Okay. Y'all acting like y them, huh?
Okay.
Like like we're struggling in Tarawi.
We like man hard.
It's only been 30 minutes.
30 minutes. That's all it's been.
You stand in Disney World line for a a attraction longer than 30 minutes.
Nah, you got the pass, huh?
A man got the pass.
30 minutes. You're like, "Yo, but you see somebody else and they're like, yo, what's auntie
taking? Yo, what's aunt taking, man?
How is Unk locked in?
I know he don't understand Arabic like yo.
You know what I mean?
I can tell. I know YOU DON'T, BUT HE'S LOCKED IN.
And I'll say when I first converted, I remember that firstawi, I didn't understand a word.
Well, w I spel I felt like God was talking to me.
I didn't understand a word that was being said, but it felt like God was talking
to me, man.
And the 20 raqat would end and I'd be like that.
Oh, what?
That's it?
How?
Ask Allah to give you the sweetness of ibada.
Oh Allah, I want I to be sweet for me.
It could happen. You know people that run.
I used to run.
I ain't going to act like I do it no more.
You know people that run.
Who likes to run?
Yo,
nobody.
But guess what? When you start running,
in the middle of the run, you'll get something called a runner's high, bro.
It's euphoric, bro.
You're in like mile seven,
exhausted,
and all of a sudden,
you're just in a flow state.
It some chemical stuff.
Yeah, whatever. Right. But imagine that was to be given to you in your ibada.
If they could do it in that, you could do it in this.
You got to ask Allah to give you that.
So the second risk that God can give you spiritually is that the ibad that starts
to taste sweet.
Starts to taste sweet.
Somebody ask for a donation.
You like come on
donate.
Let's do it. fasting in the summer.
Oh, let's go.
That's that's the level you want.
And we laugh cuz we're like, is that attainable?
Yes, it is 100% attainable.
Ask Allah to provide you that.
Number three, it's similar.
The sweetness of the Quran opens up to you.
Sweetness of the Quran.
A lot of us desire, Ya Allah, I want I want that sweetness of Quran to
touch my heart. Ask Allah to give you that.
Ask Allah to give you that sweetness where you enjoy that recitation of the Quran more
than anything else. Any music, any that Quran
hits you different
with or without understanding
understanding don't matter. You know how I'll prove it to you?
What does alif mean?
Anybody know? Nope. But it sounds beautiful.
Amazing words of Allah.
Imam starts alif you like a Allah.
Don't nobody understand what that means.
And here's the secret, yo.
Those who think they understand don't understand.
Cuz there's layers to this, yo.
There's layers to these meanings, man.
Number four,
the fourth thing that God can give you
is ha before him, a a a shame before him.
And this is a shame when you're conscious of him in private and in public.
Can you imagine if Allah gave you the ability to be conscious of him the same
way you are around Muslims when you at home?
What would you be like, bro?
You'll be a different human being.
Number five,
the is when Allah subhana wa ta'ala allows your heart
everything
as an action of his.
Whatever life is given, whatever whatever death is given, harm given, benefit given, everything you see
happen in your mind, you see it as an act of God.
Number six,
we call it then bust
that Allah subhana wa ta'ala, he causes your heart to expand
with that light of faith inside.
And we talked about that last week when we talked about this little light of mine.
I'm going to let it shine.
So, I'm not going to go over in that again.
And the last one, the last one is uh his beauty opens up to you.
His beauty, yo, his beauty opens up.
You see a little kid running around the masid, some people get angry, other people see
the beauty of Allah in that moment.
You see the beauty of Allah everywhere.
That is this next level.
Josie, he says, when you think of risk, don't think of money all the time.
Think of the spiritual things, the mental things, the emotional things that you need in your
life and ask Allah for that.
I'm going to conclude just because the time is short with uh five or six ways
to increase your risk.
Okay. The biggest one I already told you
become a river not a dam.
Number one.
Number two.
Allah says the one who has ta
what is tawa y
you know what tawa is you remember what we said slip consciousness
slip consciousness I ain't even got time to break this down but if you from up
north especially northeast when it rains out or it snows you know how to walk on
ice.
Some of y'all are from Dallas, born and raised, y'all don't know.
But when there's ice out, there's a like you got to be like nimble, you know
what I mean? Every step you take, you you place your your your weight right.
So every step you take when it's icy out, every step you take, you're conscious that
I might fall. Taqua is this awareness that every step I take in life, I don't
want to slip up.
That's taqua. That's how you live a life of tawa.
Every step you're like, "Yo, is this right?
Oh, wait. How's my weight?
How's my balance? I don't want to slip."
Tawa is the next way.
Number three,
family. Yo, take care of family.
As I talk about spending,
the first place you should be spending is on family.
Because the prophet sallall alaihi wasallam he said whoever wants their risk to be expanded
and their life extended.
Take care of family.
And that even means the uncles and cousins that you know what I mean?
Those dudes.
You know the ones that be tripping.
Y'all got cousins overseas that expect you to take care of them too.
I'll be like, "Dang, they expect it?"
Okay.
But hey, you're doing it for a different reason.
You're doing it for Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
Number four,
Allah subhana wa ta'ala says
in the Quran
uh
Allah subhana wa ta says tell the people do a lot of
Allah Ya Allah forgive me.
Ya Allah forgive me.
Your brother's like, "Yo, what happened?"
You know what I mean?
You're like, "No, I'm just I'm in a state."
The prophet sallall alaihi wasallam would be in one gathering and 70 times stay
70 times.
Because it's a relationship with God.
The verse says,
"Seek forgiveness from God."
Why? He will open the rain up.
What does rain represent?
Risk. And then he will increase.
That's the verse of Quran.
He will increase you in wealth and children.
Like this verse literally connects what
to what the risk being in increased.
And the last thing that increases our risk
is our trust in Allah subhana wa ta'ala
means trust. Trust trust.
Everything we said today was about understanding who Razak is.
I want us to leave tonight with with two main things.
Number one, become a river to God's blessings so that you can be blessed.
That means bless people.
Open up the doors of of risk so that they can open up to you.
Number two that we have to do is don't limit risk to money, y'all.
Don't limit risk to money.
They say risk.
Risk is everything that will benefit you.
That's all that is risk.
All of that is risk.
And the last thing I'm going to say is ask Allah to make you content with
what he has provided you.
Cuz I don't care how much he gives you.
If he doesn't give you contentment,
it will never be enough.
With that said, we got to wrap up.
But on the board, you're going to see a QR code
to support Kum
cuz we need you to become a river so that we can keep giving too.
Legit.
And all we're asking is for a dollar a day.
A dollar a day.
Is it on there?
Is it up there?
Let me find out.
Is it there now?
Is there a QR code?
Alhamdulillah. All we're asking is a dollar a day, $30 a month, so that we can
continue this work so that we could be a river.
You become a river.
You help us be a river.
May Allah bless you.